scientists at MIT that's a Massachusetts
Institute of Technology believe they
have found the gene which performs the
role of memory extinction they've
started doing this in mice and they can
basically isolate your bad memories
that's where this is all going this is
sort of like the movie eternal sunshine
for the spotless mind and this is where
the future is heading they'll be able to
erase our bad memories but don't our bad
memories sort of add up to the whole
human experience and where will this
lead us and I'm opening that wide open
question this is tampering with the
human experience too much I mean this is
like the beginning stages of number one
what if you know somebody's having an
off day and they slip a little bit on
whatever they're trying to you know
erase or whatever in something else get
this you know I don't know the exact
technique that they're using but I'm
saying like how close are we talking
here how can you pinpoint things and
also you know there's not a way that you
can say that one experience is just
completely eliminated without affecting
emotional responses psychological
responses you know everything it's like
a domino effect so this is gonna
completely affect your psyche and I just
don't trust that you know other aspects
aren't going to be removed and other
aspects aren't gonna be added and and I
would like to say also that in reading
the story about the mice that were
affected yes I'm gonna give space to say
you know we haven't interviewed these
mice firsthand say that those mice that
were once scared about going in the cage
and then not scared what if actually
what they're doing in their brain and
they don't know yet is they're adding
some type of like gangsta gene we're
instead that it's not that they've
forgotten it's just that like yeah I'm
[ __ ] caged I'm here and I'm not
afraid so what's up you know you never
know so what if you tamper in all this
and you just got a whole lot of hard
clothes out there well that being said I
should probably explain the study a
little bit so they use mice and they
gave them a mild electric shock when
they entered a certain cage and then
when they altered the tet1
gene in half the mice they no longer
remembered the traumatic experience so
obviously this is a long
way from getting to where it can be used
for humans and where they could actually
select the specific memory and is this
really a gangster gene and god only
knows what they're doing but don't you
think the human experience if you were
we've all had bad experiences in our
lives if you were able to go back and
erase something that happened to you
when you were eight that maybe was bad
don't you think it could cause a
cascading effect you know in the way
that you created your personality and
who you are I am with you I think that
it's disastrous I think that mistakes is
how you succeed through mistakes how
many times you've fallen how much times
you get up all that good stuff and I
believe the only risks that you regret
are the ones you didn't take in life you
know so I don't know about gangsta's not
so much might be gangsters I mean who
knows they're amplifying the gene so it
might be you know it might be like bring
it but I was sort of picturing the
hamsters from the Kia commercial a
little more badass whether or not
they're able to do this it's they
shouldn't be able to
I really don't it's it seems like it's
human experience I think that there's
something to be said for who like who
you are today is based on you know it's
gonna be like zombies like people
walking around not remembering yeah
certain things like even if it was let's
say it's a perfect science let's say
they were able to know exactly and
instruct exactly what they want to and
not refer it's like when it comes of
that anyway it's like really you know
like I don't know then you're like
weaker then it's like you're a weaker
you forgot that you've been robbed
before you're walking down the street
you're lessons from you know the Batman
right and then you'll just get addicted
to having your memory array and that's
gonna be the next thing so really this
could harm the economy because people
want to go into bars to bury their
dreams and booze this I mean this is
very much also like the movie Vanilla
Sky and memory but the Total Recall
which is my favorite science fiction
movie that they could then go ahead and
implant memories so if you can't afford
the the
vacation they can implant the memory of
the big vision I mean is this where this
is all going to a sort of matrix stuff
where we're just gonna sit in a chair
all day and have things beamed into us
and we're just the battery right we're
just the battery but it's also part of
the human experience that anything that
we develop through science we always use
you know what I mean pretty much the
only thing that was ever developed that
they stopped using was the the beta you
know instead of EHS like they oh you're
like we use everything like isn't that
part of it like even if this does really
alter how we live and for all the bad
reasons like that it's sort of part of
evolution that maybe will evolve into
into something else or am I getting a
little that is the human experience if
we've created it yeah I say keep your
memories good and bad it makes you who
you are
builds character I don't know or just
suck him out and see what happens
whoo crazy other people's memories
sucked out I would be okay with that I
just don't know if I want to have mine
set